enemies
the well-wishers came from around the
world many of them arriving days in
advance to secure the best views the
British royal family is famous for its
pageantry and Splendor and even this
scaled down event drew a massive
audience to Central London the whatnot
family had arrived from Salisbury their
father one of the pilots taking part in
the fly past after the ceremony
no chance isn't it we had a chance we
knew it'd be rainy and busy but we all
decided that it's not happened for 70
years and we had to come we've got
umbrellas haven't we
the merchandise sellers were doing a
roaring trade hats Flags umbrellas and
lots of souvenir crowns for sale plastic
rain ponchos were also in high demand
and there was the occasional familiar
face in the crowd
along with friends who traveled from
Hamilton in Scotland
what's mean to you
everything is so happy
that they should always leave for it so
long live the king
rain was forecast and for once the
weather casters were spot on but even
the drizzle couldn't dampen the spirits
of the dedicated following the
coronation ceremony on their mobile
phones the grunerbergs traveled
especially from Dusseldorf in Germany I
have the audio stream on my ears and
look like in the church and it's a
complete feeling of this moment yeah
it's great
[Music]
spectating along the Route it's quite an
experience I can tell you a sea of
umbrellas is now given way to a forest
of hands holding mobile phones all
craning their necks for a brief glimpse
of King Charles in his Carriage but the
people here say they wouldn't miss it
for the world
what kind of King will Charles be what
role should the modern monarchy have
lots of Reflections on that here I think
Charles will have his own ways but he
had a massive big role model by the
queen
and I think a lot of stuff she did he's
gonna continue
there are a few more impressive
Gatherings than a throng on the mile
approaching Buckingham Palace past Royal
occasions have seen more than a million
people congregate on this National
Boulevard and the King's coronation saw
it once again packed along its whole
length symbolic of the enduring pulling
part of the British Royals Paul Brennan
Al Jazeera Central London